what if Ariel's best friend wasn't a
fish but a merman instead would this
change everything this is a fanfic
waiting to happen
watch until the end to find out whether
the Little Mermaid would have chosen
Erik or flounder as her love what would
founder look like as a merman in fish
form flounder is beautifully bright and
colorful in yellow and blue so let's
take a moment to imagine what he'd look
like in Merman form the mermaids and
mermen in Ariel's underwater world don't
have bright yellow skin that's for sure
so we'd have to assume that flounders
yellowness would show up elsewhere on
his new Merman body flounder also has
blue stripes across the top of his body
plus he has very cool light blue and
darker blue stripes running through his
tail and fins where would those striking
features show up in merman form we'd
love to see him rocking stripy blue hair
but when you look at the other Merman in
Atlantica they all have the color hair
of regular humans the same goes for the
mermaids
you see blond black brunette gray white
and of course redheads like Ariel of
course flounder could buck the trend and
have blue hair regardless of that his
tail is the most likely place where his
true colors would show up that's where
the merpeople get to show a little
individuality you only need to look at
Ariel's sisters to see the rainbow of
colors that tails can be it's easy for
you no one cares what you look like as
for the rest of them flounder as a
merman would almost certainly be bare
chested just like all of the other guys
would that have been enough to make
Ariel see him in a romantic light keep
watching to find out what would flounder
act like as a merman so we've all got a
picture in our heads of flounder as a
merman now right let's start considering
what he'd be like as a merman and that
involves analyzing his personality as a
fish because as we're all taught from
kindergarten it's what's on the inside
that counts and fonder would surely have
the same character traits whatever form
his body took one of the most striking
things about founder is his unfailing
loyalty he sticks by Ariel no matter
what he supports her unconditionally in
every decision even when nobody else
does like her obsession with a human
world and her desire to have legs fonder
sticks by Ariel both literally and
metaphorically when
they're exploring the shipwreck and that
scary shark attacks he looks out for
Ariel like she looks out for him he also
speaks up on her behalf to King Triton
and that shows bravery but it wasn't her
fault Oh
however flounder is certainly presented
as being a bit nervous panicky and
scaring easily that's why it's so
striking when he doesn't hesitate and
coming through for Ariel it shows just
how much he loves her and fonder is
definitely in touch with his feelings
he's sensitive and is comfortable enough
to shed a tear when he feels emotional
surely these are all qualities that a
mermaid would look for in a modern
merman
are you wondering if Ariel would have
fallen in love with ponder if you were a
merman us to stay tuned as we've got a
theory on that coming up what do we
learn about flounder in the sequels
Arielle and flounder relationship in the
Little Mermaid is just the tip of the
iceberg as flounder appears in the two
sequels - he has a small part in the
Little Mermaid - returned to the sea but
he's still close with Ariel he's at the
celebration for the birth of Ariel's
daughter melody although they're apart
for 12 years given that Ariel lives on
land they become allies again they're
reunited so that flounder can help her
search for melody this time we get to
see him all grown up an adult and a
father no less with five kids in this
sequel he's braver than in the original
movie this gives us a really interesting
insight into what flounder would be like
as an adult Merman in the third movie
that little mermaid 3 Ariel's beginning
we skip back to an Arielle and flounder
were younger again he's not such a
scaredy-cat in this film
he's more carefree and adventurous than
in the Little Mermaid movie and we get a
fascinating glimpse at founders main
passions in life he adores music he's
always beatboxing and humming even
though it gets him in trouble as King
Triton has banned music we see him
working as a waiter at the catfish Club
but his big dream is being a part of the
catfish Club Band this gives even more
of a clue that they'd be super close if
he were a mer man shared interests and
passions are a great basis for a
successful relationship after all Howard
Arielle and flounder --zz relationship
change if he were a merman when things
were sure Arielle and flounder are BFFs
when she's a mermaid and he's a fish
there
together all the time so there's no
reason to think they're close bond would
be any weaker if flounder were a merman
their partners in crime exploring the
ocean together and they share a
fascination with human things one of the
things we need to consider is the
difference between two scenarios
what if flounder had always been a
merman or what if he got changed into
one if he'd been a merman for the
entirety of the Little Mermaid movie it
could have been an interesting plot
change rather than founder supporting
Ariel in her pursuit of Prince Eric he
might have been jealous and the story
could have revolved around his attempts
to show Ariel how wonderful their
underwater world is after all the other
possibility is that he got turned from a
fish to a merman and that could have
gotten really interesting his
transformation could have resulted in
Ariel seen flounder in a whole new light
the storyline might have developed about
Ariel's internal struggle who would she
choose flounder or Eric either way we
reckon the movie would have ended up
being about a love triangle let's list
all the reasons why flounder would have
won her heart reasons why Ariel would
fall in love with flounder as a merman
Ariel would never have looked at
flounder in a romantic way as a fish so
the most their relationship could have
ever been was friendship but switch
flounder into a merman and everything
changes we've already seen how fond she
is of him as a fish she comforts him
she's patient with him she's protective
over him
Ariel even risks her own life to help
him like when the shark is chasing them
through the shipwreck they even have
their own little in jokes and stock
phrases like the many times Ariel says
to him in a joking way flounder don't be
such a guppy
be it takes years to build up that kind
of relationship
it's a classic plotline in movies and in
real life you fall in love with your
best friend eventually you realize what
was right underneath your nose the whole
time so that story line could play out
for Arielle and flounder if you were a
merman it works both for if he'd always
been a merman or if he'd got changed
into one perhaps the story could go that
he saved Arielle from danger and as he
held her in his arms she had an epiphany
this was the Merman she loved however
there are reasons why it might not pan
out like that reasons why Arielle would
not fall in love with Merman flounder in
the Little Mermaid movie flounders voice
sounds quite a bit younger than Ariel's
regardless of any actual age gap as the
fish flounder comes across as pretty
young so it's not surprising that we
kind of get the feeling that Ariel looks
at flounder like a little brother and
that is certainly not conducive to
developing romantic feelings toward
someone even if flounder were Merman
their relationship might well be just as
platonic as it is when he's a different
species we're hearing shouts of
agreement from everyone who thinks
Arielle and flounder are like brother
and sister
at least scenarios eyes anyway but what
about from flounders point of view his
deep love for Ariel doesn't come across
as romantic or as brotherly it just
looks like pure love and so from his
point of view we reckon there's not much
doubt that flounder as a merman would
want a loving relationship with Ariel
the thought of her rejecting him breaks
our hearts but perhaps there's a way
that he would trump Prince Eric and
that's if flounder became a human
instead what if fonder was human we
can't help but feel that Ariel loves the
impossible she wants what she can't have
and like so many of us she finds
something seriously appealing when it's
out of the ordinary or forbidden it
could be that she falls in love with
Prince Eric's straightaway simply
because he's the first human she's ever
seen close up it could be his humaneness
that is what she's attracted to
rather than it being Prince Eric himself
that she finds irresistible if that were
the case then what if flounder became
human let's figure out how this would
work whether he started out as a fish or
a merman there are a couple of ways that
flounder could be turned into a human
the first way is the lusts of healing
and that's the same way that Arielle
originally got her legs by signing a
contract with Ursula of a sea witch what
do you think she would have wanted from
flounder in return let us know in the
comments the second wave would be how
Ariel eventually got her human legs and
that's King Triton using his magic in
his Trident to transform our people into
human people what do you think would
have happened if flounder were human
would Ariel have fallen for him or would
Prince Eric still have stolen her heart
what if Prince Eric was a merman our
final imaginary transformation is for
Prince Eric we've been setting up
flounder and Eric as the love rivals so
as we've gone through the options with
flounder as a merman and a human it's
only fair to do the same for Eric what
would have happened if Eric were a
mermaid this really puts Ariel to love
to the test and it questions what it is
that she truly finds so appealing about
Eric is it his essence his personality
who he is deep inside or is it his legs
did Eric win Ariel's affection the
moment she saw him because he was a
human a very handsome one sure and that
would have helped but is it his very
humanist that holds the main draw as a
merman Prince Eric would have the same
face hair and torso as his human self
but in place of his legs there would be
a tail that's not such a leap for our
imaginations to make as the switch and
flounder from fish to merman given that
Eric tends to wear blue trousers and a
red sash we can imagine his tail would
be along the same lines in terms of
color he'd be just as handsome maybe
even more so given that mermen are bare
chested but what Ariel's still feel that
strong pull towards him
[Music]
we don't think so
flounder versus Eric who would Arielle
choose so now it's the moment we've all
been waiting for but Arielle have chosen
mermen flounder over human Eric we know
you'll want to defend your favorite
character and it certainly is a close
call but all in all we think it wouldn't
have made any difference if flounder had
been a merman sure he might have fallen
in love with Arielle in a romantic way
but she really only has eyes for Prince
Eric
even if flounder had transformed into a
human she still would have seen him in
the same light whereas Prince Eric was
new different exciting and had only ever
been a love interest he'd never been a
comfortable friend or a brotherly figure
like flounder was before you go let us
know in the comments below if you agree
with us and sound off with your theories
on how the Little Mermaid would have
been a different movie if flounder had
been a merman and that's it please give
this video a big thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe to the things thanks
for watching
[Music]